it's not just countries in west africa
with an islamic state problem
the evolving threat is despite the
collapse of is's self-declared caliphate
in iraq and syria
the highest concentration of its
fighters are still thought to be
in this region this includes some of
around 250 british men and women on the
ground
they went out to join is or other
extremist groups
and are either detained in camps or
remain at large
across the world islamic state
affiliates have been emerging
including in afghanistan known as
islamic state khorasan
this offshoot claimed a bombing at the
weekend at a mosque in ghazni province
in which two people died and 20 were
injured
the black flag of iaf has appeared in
indonesia and the philippines
the group said it was behind a deadly
bombing during a church service on jolo
island
in the philippines in january
is also able to inspire attacks as
happened here in sri lanka
on easter sunday
hundreds of people at churches and
hotels were killed and injured by
suicide bombers
it was the deadliest is attack outside a
war zone
and raised the possibility the group is
also able to direct
and even coordinate atrocities
a video of is leader abu bakr
al-baghdadi emerged shortly after the
sri lanka bombings
he threatened more attacks in revenge
for his group's defeat in iraq and syria
it's not only is posing a threat
britain security minister ben wallace
told me terrorist group al-qaeda
is on the rise again and could be
plotting attacks on europe
well across the world aq is becoming
more busy i think that's the
all i can really say about it they are
still determined
they they they have a different
proposition
they don't see themselves as isil they
see themselves as sort of
taking a long game they're still
recruiting they're still active they're
still targeting
uh and uh you know we we shouldn't be
surprised if you see more al qaeda
plots emerging across europe and the
west
this all adds up to a challenging
security environment here in the uk
the police and the security service have
hundreds of live investigations
involving thousands of individuals and
the threat is not showing
any sign of reducing